can you tell us about the beauty of
filmmaking in Seattle yes yeah that's a
beautiful backdrop and great people it's
amazing if you need soft diffuse light
Seattle's your place see nature does it
for you yeah exactly no it's great we
have a really really tight-knit growing
independent film units so super
supportive and everybody really wants to
help out everybody else and then it's
the the even down to the mayor's office
of film and music you literally call one
person and he can give you any film
permit you need and connect you to open
office space the city-owned so you can
use this locations even just old
abandoned buildings of the city owned so
you can use these locations and then
friend we have in Seattle we have
there's it's an old military base you
can rent the hangers that are on that
military base and use them sort of as
duty the sounds not awesome but like if
you need a big empty room or like if you
need a place we're here to like torture
someone they've got all of that and
that's covered under the same permit so
it's 25 bucks a day to rent a hangar
yeah like a flick or you can fit a plane
like it's crazy yeah yeah it's just look
it's just it's easy to make movies up
there well yeah but I mean easier like
how you're not you don't have your
neighbors running after you matching
performance or like starting their lawn
mowers every time you rolled your
cameras you know it is going into I
think Seattle is just a little bit more
geared to the idea of a super small crew
and
you asked I mean we had a crew of 11 and
a cast of for that lived at a cabin for
20 days and they were all did that
voluntarily and it so that there's that
we get big production since yeah we do
have like union crew and that sort of
thing but we also have such a strong
indie community that it's not completely
outside the box to be like okay we're
going to be super and you're gonna hear
my DP you're gonna have an entire
Jeannie crew of three and you're good
and you're like excited about that yeah
you know I mean and we'd be remiss to
not mention you know we have a
phenomenal well now it just got renewed
we have a phenomenal tax incentive and
the office that one's the tax incentive
like well we don't qualify for the tax
incentives with our budget right it's
doing all the resources exactly because
like they they have a resource of like
you click on locations and see pictures
of things and like they can connect you
with all these different people and for
the big Corrections that come in you
know I think it's a it what's a five
hundred thousand dollar limit like
budget limit but the great thing is it's
a 30-percent back within 30 days tax
incentives so you don't have to you're
not getting a tax credit that you then
have to sell on a marketplace or
something like I think Alaska's is life
literally cash that you could cash back
in 30 days which you could then you know
use for post or whatever you're doing
with your movies so and I mean half a
million dollars is not a not a huge
budget so ya know I mean I they're
fantastic they're the mayor's office is
great it's just logistically or
bureaucratically they make it really
simple and then also in the largest film
festival in Seattle so we're set miss
such a film literate city which is
really nice
you